imágenes impactantes grabadas por un
pasajero
las pasajeras se pelean por la
mascarilla
y aquí una gente le niega el abordaje
completamente fuera del lugar
inapropiado y usted no va a viajar la
pasajera se rehusaba a seguir las
medidas obligatorias de salud otros una
vez dentro del avión han atacado a la
tripulación que intenta hacer cumplir
las reglas a pesar de la intervención de
uno de los pasajeros la auxiliar de
vuelo quedó sangrando los altercados en
las aeronaves de eeuu han alcanzado un
récord este año 400 en los últimos ocho
meses esto es cuatro veces más que lo
usual y las autoridades están ordenando
arrestos esto es tiranía y si nos
resistimos solo se pondrá peor
al aterrizar fue escoltada por la
policía fuera del avión
las multas de este año ya suman un
millón de dólares otro récord
en este vuelo un hombre agresivo con su
mascarilla por debajo de la barbilla fue
controlado por los pasajeros y termino
atado a su silla con cinta adhesiva
ahora enfrenta una multa de 45.000
dólares